مساعي ماكرون قبلت بانتقادات كبيره وهنا
نتحدث طبعا عن رد الرئيس الكونغولي الذي
احرج الرئيس الفرنسي على الهواء مباشره
دعونا نتابع جزءا من هذا اللقاء
يجب ان تتغير طريقه التعاون مع فرنسا
واوروبا انظروا الينا بشكل مختلف اعتقد
انه يجب ان يسود الاحترام في نظرتنا
لبعضنا بعضا اعتبرون شركاء حقيقيين لا
تنظر الينا دائما نظره ابويه مع فكره انكم
تعرفون دائما ما يصلح لنا
وفي خضم الصراع الافريقي مع الدول الغربيه
وتحديدا فرنسا تشكل استعاده مكانه روسيا
في القاره اولويه للسياسه الخارجيه للرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين خلال السنوات
الاخيره فقط نجحت موسكو في الارتباط مع
الدول الافريقيه من بوابه تقديم الدعم
الامني وتزايد النفود الروسي في كل من
السودان التشاد النيجر ليبيا الكونغو
الديمقراطيه موزمبيق زيمبابوي وبوركينا
فاسو كما تمكنت روسيا من تحقيق انجازات
مهمه اتاحت لها ان تصبح احد المشاركين
الاقوياء في السباق من اجل النفوذ في
القاره السمراء على سبيل المثال بلغت
الزياده في نسبه التبادل التجاري بين كل
من روسيا ودول القاره السمراء نسبه تجاوزت
اربعه وثلاثين في المئه منذ بدايه العام
الماضي كما تركز روسيا اليوم على
الاستثمار في مجال الطاقه والمعادن
الثمينه مع الدول الافريقيه التي تعتمد
على صادرات القمح وموارد الطاقه الروسيه
وفق تقرير حديث لمؤسسه راند للابحاث
والتطوير فانما يقرب من نصف واردات
افريقيا من المعدات العسكريه بمعدل
49% تاتي من روسيا وتشمل بطبيعه الحال
الدبابات والسفن الحربيه والطائرات
والمروحيه القتاليه